GLAZER.
WE HAVE TEN ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA
THIS MORNING WE HAVE FOR ITEMS
THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB NINE SIXTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MER MERZ SIXTY
REGARDING PESTICIDES AND THE USE
OF GLYPHOSATE.
HAS BEEN PULLED AND WILL BE A TO
YOUR BILL.
WE HAVE ONE AUTHOR HERE ALREADY
THANK YOU SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN.
IF YOU WISH TO GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED AND PRESENT SB.
SIX FIFTY SEVEN DEALING WITH
COMMERCIAL FEED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
I'M.
THANK YOU SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE FOR
COMMERCIAL FEET LICENSE AND
EXPECT AN INSPECTION TONNAGE TAX.
IN JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THIS BILL ALSO INCREASES
THE MAXIMUM RATE OF TONNAGE FROM.
FIFTEEN CENTS TO TWENTY FIVE
CENTS PER TON OF COMMERCIAL.
SOLD FUNDING USE FOR EDUCATION
RESEARCH REGARDING THE SAFE
HANDLING COMMERCIAL FEED.
THIS MAKE SURE AS WE HAVE SAFE
SPEED THROUGHOUT OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN THIS IS AN INDUSTRY BILL.
AND I WITH ME HERE IF NEEDED
THIS PEOPLE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF SPONSOR LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA GREEN SAID CH AND WE
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS GOING TO MAKE A COUPLE.
POINTS.
THE AMOUNT OF ANIMAL FEED
COMMODITIES IS IN CALIFORNIA HAS
INCREASED.
OVER THE PAST DECADE MAKING
CALIFORNIA LARGE MANUFACTURE
ANIMAL UNITED STATES.
IN ADDITION A NUMBER OF
LIVESTOCK PRODUCTION OPERATIONS
AND BERRIES AND MAKE THEIR OWN
EAT ON FARMS PRESENT IF YOU
CAN'T WIN.
AS THE S. MEMBER STATED THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION MATERIALS PROMOTE GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICE FOR ON
FARM B. MIXING.
THESE REASONS PERSPECTIVE ASTRO.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES AN OPPOSITION.
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
WILL THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN THIS MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SPELL JOHNNY AYE JOHNNY
I WILL.
WELL I HAVE A HERO.
I VALLEY.
GLAZER.
WE HAVE ENOUGH VOTES FOR THAT
BILL WILL PUT ON CALL SO PEOPLE
CAN ADD ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF WE DO THE NEXT ONE I HAVE A
YES.
OKAYUS TO THIS NEXT BILL IS THE
AG OMNIBUS BILL WHICH AND I CAN
TALK A LOT ABOUT IT IF YOU'D
LIKE ME TO BUT I WILL JUST SAY
THAT IT EXTENDS THE SUNSET. FOR
THE FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
STANDARDIZATION DE IN ANIMAL
KITCHEN GREASE AND THE
CALIFORNIA SEED Là.
EXTENDS AT SUNSET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOAT.
THAT'S EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN THE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AND DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT YES.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NOT SEVERAL
IN THE WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL MISTERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I AM SURE MEMBERS OF MANY LOUIS
BROWN ON THE UP CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
BY MEMBERS SENATOR KELLY ARE.
HAVE A QUESTION -- WHY DO WE
HAVE IN A SENSE IT ON THIS IN
THE FIRST PLACE?
THAT'S THE WAY THAT IT'S BEEN
STRUCTURE BUT WHY THINK AT SOME
POINT WE MAYBE EVEN NEED TO LOOK
AT REMOVING THAT BECAUSE HE'S A
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ALWAYS NEED
TO BE I THINK IT GIVES US A
CHANCE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THEM
ONE MORE TIME AND THINK.
IS IS STILL RELEVANT WE STILL
NEED THIS AND MOVE FORWARD.
YEAH I I AM.
I GUESS MY MY OPINION IS IS WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME DOING BILLS
IT'S JUST EXTEND SUNSET AND IT'S
GREAT GIVE US ALL SOME BILLS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY.
SIX I SAY THAT IS I'M OVER IN
THE BUT I'M BUT THERE'S SOME OF
THAT ARE.
THAT THAT REALLY DO FUNCTION
WELL AND AND IT SEEMS O ME THAT
WE HAVE THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BRING. TO BRING THAT
PROGRAMS IN AND TAKE A LOOK AT
HIM AND AND I DO IT THROUGH THE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
PROCESS BUT YEAH BUT I I SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN THE NEXT TEN TO
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT LIKE IT'S
ONE OF THOSE NO BRAINER IS IT'S
DOING A GOOD JOB IT WORKS AND
PEOPLE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ITSELF.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT OR NOT
I WILL MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
COMMENT THAT I THINK THERE'S
VALUE IN HAVING THE SUNSET IT
GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
REVIEW AND SEE IF IT'S WORKING.
AS IT SHOULD AND IT ALSO IS OF
IN IT.
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE MEMBERSHIP
OF THE DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS --
TO REALLY BE AWARE OF OF THE
PURPOSE AND WHAT THE THE
DIFFERENT KEYS.
PROVIDE. FOR THE MEMBERSHIP
INSECTICIDE THINK IF THERE'S
THERE IS TREMENDOUS VALUE IN
THAT SO.
THAT WOULD SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE WORLD.
AB FOR NINETEEN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GALGIANI AYE JOHNNY I
WILL.
WELL I HAVE A HERO NUMBER ZERO I
ELLIE GLAZER.
AND NOT.
AT ALL.
THAT BILL ON CALL YOU HAVE TO
OTHERS WITH THE AG COMMITTEE BUT
THERE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
AB EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DEALING WITH
STATE FUNDING AND PASSED ASIAN.
OR FAIRS AND THEN FINALLY AB
EIGHTEEN OH ONE DEALING WITH
CATTLE INSPECTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES YES WE CAN BE OTHER TWO
ITEMS AB FOUR OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND DEALING
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION TOOLS
PROGRAM GRANTS.
AB FOR SIXTY SIX ITEM NUMBER
THREE INTERSTATE SHIPMENTS
MARKET MILK 6% MELT.
OFFICE OF FARM TO FORK REPORT.
THAT'S MOREITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL THE SECRETARY OF
THE ROLE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR OTHERS
GALGIANI AYE JOHNNY I WILL.
WELL I HAVE A HERO.
I YELLING GLAZER.
WE WILL KEEP THE WALL OPEN ANAK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
PROBLEM AND YOU'RE HERE TO
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR EIGHTY SIX THIRTY FIVE
DEALING WITH HORSE RACING AND
STATE DESIGNATED FAIR EMPLOYEES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO DAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY
FIVE WHICH ADDRESSES A SMALL
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO ENSURE ALL
FARES.
ARE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR FUNDS
TO THE FAIRS AND EXPOSITIONS.
EXPOSITIONS FUND CREATED BY A.
B..
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THERE IS AN ESTIMATED EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS FUN.
REPAIRS TO EXCESS ACCESS
UNFORTUNATELY IN THERE WAS A
PROVISION THAT WAS OVERLOOKED IN
A BE FOURTEEN NINETY NINE
REVIVED BREAK A BARGAINING
AGREEMENT EXCEPTION.
CDFA IS CURRENTLY DRAFTING THESE
REGULATIONS IF THEY PROCEED WITH
THEM UNDER THE CURRENT STATUTE.
IT COULD FOR CLOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY FAIRS.
WHY WERE THE FUNDING?
AB SIX THIRTY FIVE MAKES THE
NEEDED TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT BY
PROVIDING AN EXEMPTION FOR
EMPLOYEES UNDER A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT THIS IMPORTANT.
ACTION AVOIDS THE NEED TO
RENEGOTIATE THESE AND AMENDMENTS
TO MIRROR THE LANGUAGE IN AB.
FORTY NINE NINE HERE WITH ME
TODAY IS LEE BROWN ON BEHALF THE
WESTERN FAIR TO ASSOCIATION WHO
IS A SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE.
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE MANAGER I
WOULD?
URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE AYE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND I'M SURE MEMBERS THE LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF THE WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE
YOUR INDULGENCE -- WITH THIS
LAST MINUTE MEASURE -- BUT IT
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT TRULY CAME
TO OUR ATTENTION UNTIL OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT FOOD AGRICULTURAL
AND SEEN THEIR DRAFT REGULATIONS.
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB --
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE EN OF
SIGNIFICANT LANGUAGE IN THERE
ABOUT HAVING TO RENEGOTIATE.
A NUMBER OF OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS IT FAIR
EMPLOYEES ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
THIS WAS NOT THE INTENT OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE WHEN IT WAS
PASSED IN AS OUR AUTHOR STATED.
LIFE IT'S NOT ADDRESS NOW MOST
FAIRS IF NOT ALL OF THEM.
WILL BE FORECLOSED FROM
OBTAINING ANY FUNDS FROM A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE SO IT IS AN
URGENT MATTER.
I AM WE APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH US ON THIS AND ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THAT BILL.
THE SECRETARY IS POSSIBLE.
SB SIX THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GALGIANI
HI JOHNNY HI WILL.
WELL I HAVE A GYRO.
DELI DELI I GLAZER.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH BOTH SMALL
PLACE IT ON CALL TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS ARRIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
AND MY HOLLOW [inaudible]
WELL I WAS WRAPPING UP SOMETHING
FOR A SPEAKING ENGAGEMENT BUT I
HAVE INITIAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
AND YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT DEALING WITH CANNABIS.
TRACK AND TRACE AND THE COURT
SYSTEM YES INDEED.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. TO BE HERE.
I AM INDEED HERE TO PRESENT AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT A RELATED
PRESERVING ACCOUNTABLE SYSTEM
FOR CANNABIS DELIVERY.
IN CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COMMUNITIES V. EFFECTIVE
INTERFACE PROGRAMS -- FOOD NAG
IS REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A TRACK
AND TRACE PROGRAM FOR OR THE
MOVEMENT CANNABIS.
THANK CANNABIS PRODUCTS
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM.
THIS ENSURES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PROTECTS AGAINST ILLICIT MARKET
SO IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ACCOUNTABILITY TOOL.
AT A MINIMUM THAT INFORMATION TO
THE MUST CONTAIN THE LICENSEE
RECEIVED THE PRODUCT TRANSACTION
DATE.
AND THE CALL TO REINFORCE
PROJECT ORIGINATE PRODUCT
ORIGINATE.
THIS BILL OF THIS REQUIRES THE
TRACK ENTRY SYSTEM TO THE SALE
POINT.
AND WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS ON THE
RETAIL PREMISES.
OR VIA DELIVERY.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE TRACK
INCREASE PROGRAM BE INTEGRATED.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS BUT YES.
BY JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
SCHOOL YEAR FROM YESTERDAY --
THE RECENT MOST RECENT ROOMS
ALSO C<c.cyan> THE DELIVERY</c>
INVENTORY LEDGER.
WHICH ALL DELIVERY DRIVERS ARE
REQUIRED TO KERRY.
ALSO BE UPLOADED TO THE TRACK
AND TRACE SYSTEM.
SO THIS WOULD PUT IN THE
ELECTRONIC SYSTEM A RECORD OF
WHAT IS IN THE VEHICLE.
ON THIS ACTUALLY INSURERS ARE
SHOULD OFFER PULLED DELIVERY
DRIVER OVER.
THEY CAN COMPARE THE UPWARD
VERSION OF WHAT'S.
SHOWN TO BE.
IN THE VEHICLE WITH WHAT'S THERE.
AND IS THERE IS ALWAYS A MATCH.
THE DRIVERS ON HIS WAIST WAS
ACTUALLY SUPERVISING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
INSURERS IT ANY ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DELIVERY DRIVER
ENCOUNTER IS BRIEF [inaudible]
AND IT.
THEREFORE ALSO SUPPORTS THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AVOIDS ANY SORT OF UNDUE DELAY --
REQUIRED TO DELIVER INFORMATION
WITH CHILDREN TRACK AND TRACE
WILL HELP ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY.
BUT LAW FORCING HAVE REAL TIME
INFORMATION OF THE CLUB SYSTEM.
AND ALLOW THEM TO FOCUS THEIR
ATTENTION ACTION ON ILLEGAL
ACTIVE AND NOT WASTE YOUR TIME
ON LEGITIMATE ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
ON AND OBVIOUSLY WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION COULD ACTUALLY HAVE
LAWFUL DELIVERY DRIVERS BEING
DETAINED UNNECESSARILY FOR
LONGER PERIODS UNNECESSARY.
SO THAT'S THE BACKDROP FOR THIS
BILL I'D BE.
ANSWERING QUESTIONS REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
I SEE YOU HERE IF YOU SENATOR
DALLY. TO HAVE WHEN ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF
OF NOR CAL CANNABIS -- WERE KIND
OF A TWEENER WHO WE WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF MR COLLES BILL
BEFORE IT WAS AMENDED.
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR RIGHT NOW BUT WORSE
CONCERNED WHETHER OR NOT THIS
CAN BE HANDLED UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM BUT WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CAITLYN IDEA WITH
EASE I IN SUPPORT OF THE INTENT
OF THE BILL AND THAT ALSO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH.
HER ON SOME CONCERNS WE HAVE
WITH DECENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND AND THEN I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AS WELL GO AHEAD.
THE RALLY SENATOR DOLLY.
THANKS DURING THE SHOW FOR
ANIMALS WE SPEND A LOT OF I AM
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE LAST
COUPLE YEARS IN ON THE TEAM OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN.
MANAGES IN AS SOMEBODY WHO.
THOSE COMMODITIES AROUND IN AND
KEEPS TRACK OF TERMINATIONS IN
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING BUILT AT THE TOO GOOD
BILL ON OR TO GETTING CYLON WE
CAN HOPEFULLY A PICK UP ON SOME
OF THOSE PEOPLE [inaudible]
AROUND ILLEGALLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS THIS BILL
GOING TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT'S BECAUSE I TURN ON MY
STAFF IT DID IT DID IT GO
THROUGH THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
TODAY HE ALREADY RIGHT OKAY.
DID YOU GO TO PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
PROBLEM WE NOT OKAY I DO I JUST
HAVE.
CONCERNS ABOUT OW LAW
ENFORCEMENT FEELS ABOUT THIS AND
HOW.
HOW IT'S INTEGRATED WITH THE
EXISTING SYSTEM AND AND WHETHER
IT?
PERHAPS OVERWHELMS THE CLIENT
SYSTEM OR IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY WANTING THAT
THEY BELIEVE WILL.
STREAMLINE AND HELP I I'M NOT AS
FAMILIAR WITH HOW THIS WOULD.
WOULD WORK IN A PRACTICAL MATTER
COULD YOU GIVE US SOME EXAMPLES
ET STARTED TO WHERE YOU'RE
SAYING THAT A DELIVERY TRUCK.
PERHAPS GETS STOPPED AND IF THE
LOAD MATCHES.
THE LOADED SEND THE SYSTEM THAN
THEY THAT PERSON CAN MOVE ON IS
IT THAT EVERY TIME THERE'S A
LOAD [inaudible]
THAT IS.
HELLO DIANA PLANS DELIVERY THEN
THAT WOULD BE IN THE CLASS
SYSTEM OTHERS ALREADY
REQUIREMENT THAT DAY.
THAT THEY HAVE THE DELIVERY
LEDGER [inaudible]
ARM.
BUT WE HAVE IN FORCE ASSISTANT
INCORPORATES OFFICERS OUT ON THE
ROAD CREWS IN ABOUT.
THEY CAN TRACK IT DOWN
[inaudible]
BUT BUT KNOWING WHAT'S ON THE
VEHICLE DOES BECOME IMPORTANT OF
POLICING ACCOUNTABILITY AS IT'S
MOVING AROUND THE STATE.
SO WE HAVE NOT HEARD OF A LOT.
I GUESS I THINK.
IT'S SORT OF A GAP IN THE IN THE
SYSTEM.
SAY WE WANT LAW ENFORCEMENT OUT
THERE TO MAKE SURE THE DELIVERY
THE DELIVERY SYSTEMS WORKING
WELL -- IT SUPPORTS COMMUNITIES
TO KNOW THAT WHAT.
IN ON MARIJUANA TRAVéS THEIR
COMMITTEE IS IS UNDER SYSTEM AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- I DON'T THINK
THAT THE BUT I DO HAVE TO SAY
CENTER I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS.
THE DELIVERY DRIVERS OF LEDGER
SO THEY CAN MATCH UP IF THEY
HAVE A STOP.
WE'VE NOT HEARD THAT THAT'S A
PROBLEM NATIONAL FUNDING OF
PATIENTS.
OUT THERE AVAILABLE -- THERE'S A
YEAR TO IMPLEMENT.
A YEAH I ACTUALLY HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYTHING FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OBJECTING TO IT.
AND I THINK THE COMPELLING IDEA
IS IT JUST SUPPORTS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IF THEY HAVE A
STOPPING ABLE TO CONFIRM THAT
THIS IS.
THE LOTUS REPRESENTATIVES BEING
OUT THERE ON THE STREET AND
THEY'RE OFTEN ON YOUR WAY.
BUT ACTUALLY SUPPORTS THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
FROM DOWN TIME TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT.
DO YOU HAVE WHAT YOU SHOULD.
AB WHAT YOU'VE REPRESENTATIVES.
THE OBLIGATION TO HAVE A DELIVER
LEDGER IS ALREADY ON THE CASE.
SO WHAT'S IT THAT'S NOT NEW IT'S
JUST SUPPORTING THE BILL OF LONG
FORCE ACCESS.
I GUESS I DON'T HAVE A HE KEREN
SO THE NAP BUT WE WE WE'VE NOT
HEARD ANY PROBLEM [inaudible]
AND AS THE CENTER LOSE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE MARIJUANA
DISCUSSION SINCE FIFTEEN SINCE
YOU TO DO REGIONAL. TO BILL
[inaudible]
HE YEAH I HAD I HAVEN'T HEARD OF
OBJECTION FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BEING AHEAD
OF OF THIS SAND BEFORE BECOMES A
PROBLEM AND AND SUGGESTING THIS
PROPOSAL.
I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WOULD WORK IN
A WITHIN THE SYSTEM I KNOW FOR
MYSELF.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH MISSING
PERSONS CASES AND HAVE HAVE DONE
SOME LEGISLATION DEALING WITH
BACK AND I KNOW THAT WHEN
SOMEONE GOES MISSING IT GOES
INTO -- A SYSTEM AND THEN IT IS
ALSO TRANSMITTED TO THE CLASS
SYSTEM WHEN WHEN THERE'S A HIT
ON SEPT.
OR LEAD ON SOMEBODY THAT MAY.
BE MISSING WHO POTENTIALLY IS
FOUND THAT'S AUTOMATICALLY
SUBMITTED TO THE CLASS.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH -- OLDER MISSING
PERSONS CASES FOR EXAMPLE WHERE
THEY WERE NOT PUT INTO THE
SYSTEM AT ALL -- AND SO THERE'S
SAID.
A GAP N..
OLDER CASES.
NOT BEING IN THE SYSTEMAND
NEWER CASES BEING IN THE SYSTEM
AND ALSO.
THERE WERE [inaudible]
REQUIREMENTS THAT.
REQUIRED IN CERTAIN CASES AND
NOT IN OTHERS AND SO FORTH SO
IT'S NOT A 1100% GUARANTEED
SYSTEM WHERE YOU CAN RELY ON
SOMEBODY WHO'S MISSING BEING IN
THAT SYSTEM.
SO WITH THOSE PROBLEMS THAT
EXIST IT MAKES ME WONDER -- IS
THIS.
TRULY THE PLACE BUT WE SHOULD BE
TRACKING THIS KIND OF THING AND
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH.
ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY END OF OF
WEATHER.
THAT ACTUALLY IS WORKABLE AND DO
A FULLER WITH CREATING ANOTHER
SET OF PROBLEMS WELL.
I GUESS THE OVERALL THE RESPONSE
I HAVE.
YOU KNOW I OFTEN.
IT'S FUNNY IS A LAWYER WHEN I
SIT DOWN AND DRAFT A BILL.
I DO MY BUILD DRAFT AND I HANDED
TO PEOPLE LOOK AT BECAUSE IN OUR
BUSINESS BILLS GALLON HAVE TO BE
BACK.
IN MY VIEW IS ALWAYS BEEN WELL.
I'LL TAKE MY DRAFT.
AND I LIKE THE WAY I'M DOING IT
WRONG -- THE WAY YOU'RE DOING IT
NOT AT ALL.
SOME IS GONNA TAKE A WHACK AT IT
GOT TO PUT AN IDEA OUT THERE I
THINK.
WE DEFINITELY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
THE LEAGUE.
MARKET PLACE.
LEGAL MARKET PLACE.
IS THE CONCURRENT EXISTENCE OF
AN ILLEGAL MARK [inaudible]
AND WE THE GREAT VENTURE OF
TRYING TO BRING RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA TO THE MASSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS VERY DEPENDENT UPON HAVING
THE SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT LEGAL.
AND SORT OF STAMPED DOWN ON
ILLEGAL.
AND THE SYSTEM RELIES UPON THE
MOVEMENT OF MARIJUANA AROUND TO
VENDORS OTHER [inaudible]
CHANNELS [inaudible]
SO.
THAT MOVEMENT AND MAKING SURE IT
IS OF THE LEGAL PRODUCT.
IS ACTUALLY ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONING TO A
HEALTHY MARKET PLACE.
IT TIES INTO TAX REVENUES.
AND NOT HAVING LEAKAGE --
ILLEGAL.
THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF PUBLIC
INTEREST THE CONVERGES UPON.
THE MOVIE TO MARIJUANA TO THE
SYSTEM.
AND SUPPORTING [inaudible]
RELIGION OPERATORS.
AND DOWN ON THE ILLEGAL.
SO I FEEL LIKE.
PUT IN A TOOL.
IN THE TOOL KIT.
WHICH IS THE ESPECIAL THIS BILL.
ALONG OR SEND REAL TIME.
THEY STOPPED THE VEHICLE TO HAVE
THE POTENTIAL LOOK UP TO SEE
WHAT TO EXPECT TO FIND IN THIS
VEHICLE.
WHAT DO I SEE HERE?
WHAT DELIVERS HAVE ALREADY MADE
OKAY THAT MEANS WE'RE NOW DOWN
OF THESE ITEMS AND ARE THEY HERE?
AS RUNNING ELSE.
IT WILL ALLOW FOR TRAFFIC STOPS
TO BE SEATED MORE PATIENT MANNER.
AND ANYBODY WHO'S IN BUSINESS AS
A DELIVERY DRIVERS NEVER COME IS
OUR THEY DON'T WANT TO SPEND
TIME.
AT THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
YOU KNOW.
WHILE PEOPLE KIND OF GO BACK AND
FORTH ON THE SYSTEM TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT [inaudible]
SO.
IT IS IN PRINT HAS BEEN IN PRINT
NOW FOR A WHILE I WOULD EXPECT
TO HEAR FROM LONG OR SENATE'S.
IT'S IT'S LOOKING TO A DATE A
YEAR ROUND WHEN THE SYSTEM IS
SUPPOSED TO BE UP AND RUNNING.
I THINK ULTIMATELY IT UP HOLDS
THE PUBLIC VALUES OF REGULATED
MEDICAL.
REGULATE MARIJUANA IN THE
MARKETPLACE [inaudible]
THAT IS.
PASSES TO COMMUNITIES IS
ACCORDING TO PRESCRIBE NORTH
STATE SET UP.
SOMEONE DOESN'T CARE FOR
MARIJUANA.
WE STILL FEEL THAT THEIR LIFE IS
NOT.
UNDULY IMPACTED.
SO IT'S SORT OF A POLICY
RATIONALE [inaudible]
I I APPRECIATE YOUR EXPERIENCE
VIEW POINT.
THAT THERE CAN BE A LOT OF
COMPLEXITIES SYSTEMS AND MY SORT
OF CROSSING MY FINGERS AND
WHISTLING PAST THE GRAVEYARD IS
I BRING THIS IDEA OF BOARD
SAYING [inaudible]
GREAT IDEA.
I APPRECIATE THAT I'M.
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE A
MOTION ON THE BILL TO MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A MEETING
WITH YOU AND SOME INDIVIDUALS
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT JUST TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT IT AND
AND SEE AND SEE IF.
IF WHAT YOU'RE ENVISIONING AND
WELL -- WE MAY APPROVED TODAY.
IS WORKABLE OR IF IT NEEDS --
SOME ADDITIONAL EYES AND
ATTENTION TO IT SO THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE GOOD PBLIC POLICY.
AND A VERY NEW AREA I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE PAST AND JUST WOULD
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING IT RIGHT.
AND I DON'T KNOW A KNIFE ABOUT
HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
AND TO TO HAVE A SENSE OF OF
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO WORK IN
PRACTICE SO.
I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE I WILL
PURSUE THAT MEETING IN MY STAFF --
AMANDA -- CHERYL WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH MENDES
IDEA ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR CAVEA.
WHY JUST HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE
I'M BEING ASKED TO VOTE TODAY ON
SOMETHING THAT FOR ME AND I'M?
I'M COMFORTABLE DOING THAT BUT
BUT I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE MAY
BE SOME MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
IS IT ANTICIPATED THAT IT THE
BILL CHANGES THAT'LL COME BACK.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT.
I WOULD PROPOSE THAT WE COULD
BRING IT BACK WE COULD
[inaudible]
I WOULD.
I THINK IF WE COME UP WITH
FURTHER CHANGED -- FOR THE CHAIR
I WILL ACTUALLY PERCENT BRIEF
YOU ON TOP [inaudible]
OKAY.
WITH THAT I WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE THE BILL.
AND WITH.
THE EXPECTATION THAT WILL HAVE
THAT MEETING AND IF THERE ARE
CHANGES WE WILL WE CAN ALWAYS
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL.
THANK YOU THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GALGIANI
HI JOHNNY I WILL.
WELL I HAVE A ZERO ZERO I VALLEY.
KELLY I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I LOOK FOR THE WORKING WITH
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE.
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO DEALING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS
CRAB COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THROUGH THE WORK OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK DONE
LATELY WITH RESPECT TO THE
DUNGEON S. CRAB FISHERY AND
THERE IS IN FACT A TASK FORCE
THAT IS WORKING ON IT.
ESPECIALLY AROUND YOUR USAGE AND
IN TANGLE MINTS BUT IT.
SEEMS LIKE IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
TIME NOW SINCE IT'S SUCH A LARGE
FISHERIES THE MOST ABUNDANT
CRABBET REPRESENTS MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF INDUSTRY
ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST AND
THIS IS AN ICONIC.
SPECIES.
DISABILITIES TIME THAT WE CREATE
A COMMISSION SO THAT THE
INDUSTRY CAN GET TOGETHER AND
FACE.
THE ISSUE SAID IT HAS BANNED AND
THE ONGOING ISSUES THAT THEY
WILL ALSO FACE NOT JUST THE WILL
ENTITLEMENTS BUT TO MOW GAS SAID.
MARKET RATES AND OTHER THINGS
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
FACING.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO HAVE A CATTLE
COMMISSION WE HAVE TO SEE YOUR
TRANSMISSION THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF OTHERS.
BUT THIS IS AN ICONIC SPECIES
FOR CALIFORNIA MADE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BOATBUILDER
ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS AND WHERE THE
SPONSOR THE MEASURE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS SENATOR
WELL.
HAVE A QUESTION I BELIEVE ON I'M
FINE WITH THE BILL BUT I WAS
DOWN IN IN CHILE LAST NOVEMBER.
AND THE ART ARTISANAL FISHERMEN
THERE HAD TO CHANGE WHAT THEY'RE
CATCHING BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I'M WONDERING IF CLIMATE CHANGES
HAD AN IMPACT ON ON THE CRAB IN
CALIFORNIA IT HAS IN FACT TO MOW
CAST SAID.
GROWTH WHICH IS AN AL COMES OUT
OF AN ALGAL BLOOM.
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
WE'RE SEEING DIFFERENT PATTERNS
OF ALLERGIES IN THE WATER AND IN
FACT EVEN ON SHORE FRESHWATER
SPECIES THAT GET IN AND CARRY
TOXINS IN THE WATER.
SO WITH THE AMOUNT OF CARBON
IT'S INCREASING AND A LOT OF THE
CHANGES THAT HAVE [inaudible]
WATER TEMPERATURES.
DEFINITELY IMPACT ON THIS AND
OTHER FISHERIES WHICH IS WHY
IT'S TIME THEN THEN THIS IS
APPROPRIATE TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INDUSTRY HAS A PLATFORM TO
BE TALKING ABOUT THEIR
CHALLENGES.
AND THEN WORK WITH -- PC AND
FISHING GAME AND THE OTHER
AGENCIES THAT THAT ARE IN THE
STATE MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
ISSUES ARE BEING.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
DALLY.
I JUST WANNA SAY IT I SAID ON
THE COMMISSION WITH THE TO
MEMBER STONE AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS IS A THIS IS A LONG TIME
COMING AND NOT.
I THINK IT'D BE GOOD FOR THE
FISHERY IN AND WE CAN DO SOME
GOOD WORK OUT THERE SO I'LL.
PUT YOUR BILL ALREADY BEEN MOVED
IN.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION ON YOUR
BELL.
GRADUATIONS IN THIS ARE THE
MOTION IS TO MOVE THE BILL.
TO ASSEMBLY ARE SENATE JUDICIARY.
THE SECRETARY THIS CALL WILL.
BE FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY RIVER SPELL JOHNNY.
JOHNNY I WILL.
WILL I EVER. ZERO ZERO I DALY.
KELLY I GLAZER.
GLAZER I'D.
GRADUATION SAMBIL IS OUT.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS.
WE WILL START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
EIGHTY FOUR OH NINE EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY SIX AB EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN OH ONE WITH THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATORS
DALLY.
KELLY I GLAZER.
GLAZER HI.
THAT IS INCLUDED.
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR
NINETEEN DEALING WITH GOOD KNACK
OF CULTURE.
AUTHORS THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE.
WELL THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB FOR NINETEEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
SPELLING.
SALLY I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT AB SIX THIRTY
FIVE I ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW.
ON THE WALL.
SB SIX THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS HAVE AERO.
AERO I PLACER.
LATER I AM BILL IS OUT.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN DEALING WITH.
MARSHALL FEED THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS.
CREATION SENATORS VALLEY.
SALLY I GLAZER [inaudible]
I I THE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH